[Musik]
die einzige ronja wie bloß ich einmal
ich bis jetzt gemacht
erzählt macht dann sind jugendliche so
früh reif und frivol wie ihr ruf in
diesem film sagen sie wie enthemmt oder
enthaltsam sie wirklich leben
[Musik]
diese zehn jugendlichen haben sich auf
unseren aufruf im blick gemeldet sie
treffen sich hier zum ersten mal und
reden miteinander erstaunlich offen über
ihre ersten erfahrungen mit sex und
liebe
ist sex mit 13 zu früh
sie reiner aus meilen sagt nicht
unbedingt
für mich ist es schön sexy aber ich muss
sagen wir sind zwar noch nicht ganz
barock sie dazu an diesen vorschlag
findet sie aber ich habe nicht wirklich
verschlag die erfahrung gefunden weil
sich 60 sieht das jetzt nachbereitung
oder so eingerichtet dass ich mit meiner
festen fringer haben nicht einfach
laufen
ja mit seiner show sehr frühe aber
trauern hat sie natürlich zum beispiel
zeigt man nicht aus
[Musik]
die stelle wo es entdeckt ist spiele ich
einen film im schlaf und elbe mir und
dann vielleicht anfang macht am anfang
aber dann haben wir
ja
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja so tiemann
ich
glaube
also ich sind sechs mitglieder bis
schönes was mich erzählt oder man
anwalts am anderen geschlecht das ist so
einfach im ort ihres leidens wie sei
gestellt hat so zum leben
halten das ist so ganz anders gibt es
neues entdeckt also
nicht ganz was mitzunehmen
[Musik]
mir gefällt's man einem mann ihre hat an
der intelligenten ich auf 6
eine freundliche ist wenn der höfliche
stereotypische respekt er hat filme ist
damit genauso viele
[Musik]
in
was mit den freunden jetzt sagen dass
ich es noch kann will ein anderer bub
hat sozusagen trikot hat mir noch nicht
so von sms schreibe ich dann muss ich
sagen ich bin nach retro wie kann man
auch flirtet wenn zum beispiel ein
nutzungs nach gemacht was er wollte sagt
ins land dann immer so gern mitgemacht
was ich auch verstehen
und dann haben wir halt obama konnte
hier aus in einer und so ich mache mich
lief süchtig machen nicht ruhig und dann
nichts sagt er ich werde auch ich würde
das so fertig macht wieder zu dir zu
groß
und dann hat er aber gefunden es geht
nicht so weiter und hat dann gesagt es
ist jetzt fertig vielleicht kann man das
mal wieder später machen sozusagen
jetzt haben wir mal fertig weiß noch
nicht wie es weitergeht
die burgenländer
hatte wird nicht durchführen kann mich
also spezielle verliert ihn
nicht einerlei und mit dem anderen flirt
darum geklebt und david
fitz darum finde es schon gut dass mit
ihm zusammen sind
allgemein betrachtet nicht dass
jugendliche deutlichen 6 1 zum beispiel
vor 20 jahren das erste mal passiert
meist irgendwann zwischen 15 und 17 oder
zum teil auf werte zwischen 8 und 17 air
berlin von arx hat schon tausende von
jugendlichen über sex liebe oder
partnerschaft kurz über herzschmerz
aller art beraten
wer hat den pariser in der tasche
was auch immer noch im hinterkopf weißt
du solltest du mindestens immer noch
wisse er
frau das buch darstellt mit wolf kondom
was dann
würde
[Musik]
der jobs for
gaza oder
allgemein
das kondom dann heißt es schnell mal vom
ja ich passte scharf ich weiß ja wenn
ich muss zu fördern und also die eu
sagte finden
die unsicherheit in der pubertät kann ja
bewirken dass man sich
oder dass man eigentlich gar nicht mich
dass andere sind wie unsicher man sich
fühlt und das kann dazu führen dass man
wirklich sich so stereotyper flüchten
sie sich nicht sogar wirklich ganz klar
in der pornografie vermittelte ideal von
sexualität zum beispiel verpflichtet was
man denkt ich orientiere mich jetzt
darauf ich bin ich jetzt so verhalten
wie das geht zeigt wird und dann
natürlich die durch erweckt haben sich
total abklärt mehr wissen absolut und
dass ich dann oft war man mögliche
tiefer geht gar nicht
geht mit alkohol alles leichter
als ronnie und die chemie sind sich
nicht mehr so sicher sie wollen in
diesem papier spiels über ihre liebes
abenteuer reden
[Musik]
die drei sind durch dieses filmprojekt
zu freunden geworden
ja so etwas gibt es könnte es gebrauchen
die meisten solcher
sturm ist
verschiedene flur
sich so sieber
[Musik]
das nicht
mitzieht dann gemerkt dass ich direkt
wählbar und was mir noch schlimmer
kürzlich hat mich ein klein wenig auf
diese gesprochen hat so was sie selber
sein ob sie empfehlen jetzt kriegt ja
schon wieder gut und sie zieht und so
eigene feier dass sie oder sangen für
und dadurch eine junge
patientin makro
sie also ja auch ziemlich
genau mit sie stetige zweitlängste und
sehen also
so aus chicago wo schlussendlich
zumindest abschnitt vier starter ich bin
wahnsinnig drucker wurde ja ein
schwenkarm
[Musik]
auch elke frauns betrüger für das denn
noch zu sagt sie
gleichzeitig kann glaub ich auch von
meinen jetzt woche steht seit sie sich
mit dem lebensmotto
extras
ist genauso bis das ist schnee von oben
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich konnte mal wieder mal für und den
habe ich immer wieder intensiv
ja so lange dass das passt das natürlich
gleich dass da gibt es schon aber es
ist gut dass meine
frau lück als er gemerkt
das ist nicht mein
recht
guter sex
natürlich an der frauen das natürlich
noch besser
[Applaus]
[Musik]
schönemoor
der premier ist ich sie und jetzt
kann ich ruhiger gibt so ist das
buch klasse vom
us militär ist der perfekte verführer
das ist so lud trixi wie musik muss herr
stevens präsentieren sagt musalek das
problem dass das
produkt oder
das neue stadion ist kleinkram da der
zur klasse und hat über das probiert
sich die funktioniert
sowie
ist
dazu mit
zwar das heißt als glückloser chef
jeff kindler
für jugendliche pornografie ist zu eis
vorbild ich was ich sage oder unter
gruppendruck das gefühl hat dass wir
jetzt noch machen denn ich das zeitlich
und hans kann mit möglichkeit ihre
ureigenen fantasien entdeckt ihre
sehnsucht und die luft wirklich einsatz
finden wie die sind und dann die auch
umsetzen sondern sind dann wirklich
quasi überrannt von so pornografische
bilder wo er stattfindet und was ich
danke so müssen sie das land ganz groß
genug
das ist mir eigentlich
ganz gut klar ist dass die ich musste
wirklich mein sohn und
meine rechte erfahrung gemacht mit sechs
und hat möchte dass dieses thema
ihr beruf
das ist fakt dass im illegal aber wenn
man sex mit der frau das ist welche in
das gestein vor was du suchst aber
richtig ist es für die haut einfach ein
job wie jeder andere wie ich mich drüber
muss verkaufen mit jetzt halt mit dem
ausland sehr wichtig abgabe kann da
waren sondern mehr rechtzeitig zugang
erlaubt ist natürlich trotzdem so dass
jugendliche die aus einer
übersexualisierten gesellschaft mit
pornografie sich das ansieht
wozu schaut man pornos
[Musik]
verbreitetes video blog wird
zentimeter milliarde pollen als einziger
ist aufgeheizt film und ist genau das
aber mag es nach vorn und nicht
wie erwachsene beliebten saga die hütte
jugend ich sehr vorne orientierte und
alles gelernt das ist nicht so dass
jedoch wie es jetzt ich denke mir jetzt
viel mehr zugang zu prognos hat redet
mir auffiel meter über das sich nun
einfach so ist tabu thema weil die
unterwäsche schrittmotor 32 jährige
tragen trank aus das gehört dazu ohne
dass das unbedingt bedeutet dass sie
damit waren in erster linie provozieren
oder zum ausdruck bringen dass sie
unbedingt sechs möchte da und dann
konzentriert dass zum beispiel
sonnenschule hört einfach auch als
modisches accessoire sie für jugendliche
und dass sie sich zum teil gar nicht
bewusst sind was sie ausstrahlen kann
oder will kriegt man sie
[Applaus]
dieses mini rechner hat nicht rund
lief es
existiert zum konsumgut wurde das nicht
unbedingt nur im erotik das ist
natürlich weg in die medien überall ist
es ja so dass
sexuelle inhalte zu benutzt werden
größer schafft je nachdem
großes glück dass wir nicht schon
jetzt so richtig
es ist irgendwie
unterklassig gespielt ist ein porsche
gar nicht dass kurz vorbildlich was
nicht sie schon jetzt dass sich pornos
0,6 grad das ist so und hat eine falsche
vorstellung gegen hier und sie spart
sich so was finde ich ja bis herz und 16
gibt es ein leben nach der pubertät
[Musik]
melanie hat sich schon früh ausgetobt
mit der mutter im blut sah man glaubt
mit
seines
opels ganz wieder schwanger geworden
aber dazu und fertig macht und
nach immobilien bin mit dem freund
zusammen
[Musik]
beliebt
und wieder in die ausgangssituation
als
trainer erkennen
und als im schlusssatz haben ein bett
gelandet
wo sie ein halbes jahr zeit also den
himmel mit kondomen verhütet und er in
einem akw kondom verhütet bis 10 und wie
sie wissen bin schwanger war
verstorben
[Musik]
aber wie wird das schon machen und als
wäre die superscharfen
ist damals auf 3g
empfang war also in nrw gegeben
nach rund reform sven kalisch meistens
dann vormittags
mit dem spieler und als mieter auch
heute freundlich und wer nicht dem
regime habe war das so
und nachmittag mit afrika spazieren
geschlafen
und spielte sich mit immer nach und das
schönt erinnert uns nach das
nächste mal wieder spazieren also liebe
dafür sicher wichtig dass man
mitbringen und
sagen wir
rummel macht deswegen schaue ich dass
man blätter
[Musik]
wohin für das erste mal
die zwei jüngsten lina und luca aus
affoltern am albis vergnügen sie jeden
freitag mit ihrer clique zwischen coop
und mcdonald's
raum zu zweimal war seine würden kalla
vom megatrend
vorstellig wurde und zwar am strand aber
ich komme jetzt ein duft motiv und
die identität ist
also wenn ich die person gesehen wie die
klimaziele und so denn wenn ich mit
ihrem lied und zu deiner scheinlich
megaschön und es wäre cool wenn man
sammelt windows macos schönes gefühl mit
leanback schlafen aber
an ihr sexuell
erfolge gesendet ich finds kann
nachteilig sind
der mantis da wenn der hund und den mars
hinter sich also ich kann nicht sauer
person die stadt längst raus gegangen
will er unbedingt wähler drei jungfrauen
bis sie und noch eine partie und den
sadistischen akt
[Musik]
also für eine petitesse klassisch ganz
schlimm
erzählt
und wo noch ein zittersieg machte
kalus zum dessen mache
ich glaube da wohl ins leben machen von
dem was
man macht das will ich jetzt mir sage
ich es einfach
und ich glaube man brauche zwar meine
freunde war jetzt so erwartet
gegeneinander sind ja mehr auf sechs
aufgestockt
ohne
[Musik]
die kollegin
annika
die große attraktion
warum sind männer keine [ __ ]
[Musik]
gestik
ich bin
und dass ich auch so und alles auf
einmal auf 1 2 jede schule und damit der
kollege hat das anders google bin ich
bei dem man sowieso
hilfe chronik für alle mini kollegen
dann sich einen erhalten weil ich die
pubertät rubin und nicht mal richtig
stressig mit der mutter denn ich nur
freuen die in der 2 und dann eigentlich
immer freundin aus radbruch treffen soll
das bad jetzt
erfolgte 2001 berufswahl und alles noch
vor mir habe ich es besser beim cooper
teils mit toyota sowie co
wenn denn
sportlich hoch im kurs
[Musik]
wenig zur freunde kommen könig
sind so kollege vor den kollegen
ehrungen man damit durch sind und so und
noch immer hat man die richtige kann
nicht klappen
dann ist 118 alle bezirk aber die
beträge hand einfach da nicht lang hebt
und deswegen so wahnsinnig lang herbert
und dann halt zwischen tura hat eine
zulage stopft gemacht eine woche oder so
und dann wird man schneller schlumpf
mehrere schön der kurze zeitraum hat
potenziale kreativ er will mehr möglich
und
war mir nur ein ferner machten einfach
gott zwei frühen der innerhalb von
minuten korn dann wird man gerade
schlapp abstand vielleicht aber bürger
die könnte ihn ja eine woche haben sie
werden eher schlapp also auswahl
wichtiger baustein lösungen sind dann
die größte und
sie beim kings und olli andere bürger
sind doch so und so und das meine ich
weiß gar nicht wer da so sekunden hat
dass diese so gott olli bewundere sie
dass sie schon so viel content und wenn
makler ausfiel burgenland sind [ __ ]
wieso weiß ich aus internationalem
profil
also
besonders ich will eigentlich nicht so
finde
ich das nicht so gut vor allem ich
bin wenn ich jetzt einfach nur mit ist
beckham wird dann werde ich so
vorstellen als [ __ ] stampfen das
wetter spielt
[Musik]
im frühen geschäft nicht geregnet in
wieder ablauf häuser bitte es kommt
einfach bis gut und mein name ist also
wissen ich zum beispiel habe ich gott in
der pause gemacht
bios interpretiert und dann
noch zwei stunden
und dass ich den wecker und dann ist
einfach so kleinigkeiten
ich will ihre und als ich meine ganze
gemacht haben was hier mag seiten
und da am wochenende rund 84 zu mir hey
aber
als telefon und nimmt das finde ich
schlimm das telefonieren
ich hatte einfach kein freund halten die
regeln
[Musik]
denn so oft ihr viertel vor elf uhr
trafen rosalie vita und dann ging es mit
der linie besser kollegin zu der
lena-hype und noch einer bliebe es bei
diesem hobby 12 warum ich mit
kollegen halten
[Musik]
wie merkt man dass manche wohl ist
ich würde auch noch jemand ganz
besonderes gesehen und haben wir denn
hier mit einer mit zu den besten song du
bist single
is ja sie ist dabei so aus
wie lange ein bisschen mit einem freund
zusammen
sondern ich mich jetzt erstmal mit
verfahren
erinnere macht dann ist das sehe ich bin
wie die heikelsten der like sie dann bin
ich ins bett kochen
hat mir ankommt kommt aus die ganze zeit
lag zugleich leuten nicht gerade richtig
machen dann
kann ich mir aber leid so warum
kritischen einfach nur
neugierig zu machen und haben uns
größtenteils
der e mails die sie für welche aufgaben
und
das ganz speziell
in zürcher schwulenclub b & m hat sandro
seine szene gefunden
[Musik]
und ich dann der staustufe gelöst haben
was abgelöst haben mir gesagt dass mir
so schlimm ist für mich kann ich es mit
der frau sowie sagt mit der frau das
durch oder wie ist das klar
einig
sind sich als kollegin gut aber
metaphern und sohn ist froh dass ich
schwul bin
eigentlich sehr rote schimmer von
reden wir doch nicht alles das bereits
so
zum beispiel das bildformat
am strand immer nur wenn die dh
umgebaut mit spitzenforschern habe das
finde ich echt noch tätig
als erster
das schwul bin und der teich zeit zu mir
wenn du damit glücklich bist dann bin
ich das auto nichts mit glauben und mit
dem ort terminen auch sie total falsch
agiert hat mich auch immer man sehr
verletzt aber sie hat sich einer knie
wieder entschuldigt und seinem ruf
darüber reden aber
völlig zusammen
das finde ich in meiner familie
sexuell im monat finden die er redet
über die gefühl
wieder homosexuelle
mir redet sehr oft mit dem gefühl mich
ein
warum man jetzt sind wir uns
bewusst machen
wenn ich mal mit kann alleine macht das
meiste muskeln mit den autor
kalach
latif
schnellbahntrasse hatte sich im
brandfall und dann noch ein tanz selbst
trinkt nach dem
duschen und im muss gar
nicht so gut laufen kann und gott noch
mitten ins bett oder macht die sache
jetzt rechnet zumindest auch das alles
nur für mich gehört das thema sex gehört
ich liebe und ich finde 6 für mich
wenn ich sex haben mit dem ich nicht
leben dann stimmte sex ziemlich
einzurichten ist für mich nicht so schön
die aufspaltung dass man sagt ich möchte
aber wegen sexueller erfahrung abkaufen
damit ich nachher quasi mich sicher
fühle mich wirklich auf pc spieler das
hat natürlich auch dass man sich das
sagen wieso tracht light oder das
vermeintlich rand ich merke aber sehr
oft dass die 3 liga wie logisch ist
heute der betrieb
zum glück ist das gang und mainz iii
einer
und dann hier haben
ja
ja ja
ich habe nämlich christen so und den ich
eigentlich nicht wirklich braucht
und
ich meine jetzt nicht so da hatte ich
heute mal durch
wo finden junge frauen was sie suchen
celine kamen und hanna laura bereiten
sich auf einen gemeinsamen ausgang vor
mit masturbation und
nachahmer präparate mit dem frieden
dienen
herzig aus und so und da hat mein erster
festen kollegen erste gummi
und der hat möchten sowie auf eine
vierer ist liebeslaube also erstens
china habe ich um und habe mich gefragt
wie man das kino zusammen klinsmann
handlichkeit und so hoch fange
das ganze in ruhe das fürs haus vor der
pubertät
[Musik]
viele andere viele andere harrten auf
das erste mal
luft entwickelt und
sind stark und frauen sind die awo
ausknipst werde wieder frau also ich
anerkennen ausgang und dass er hätte
hätte ich gerne bis mit auch irgendeinem
und dann sich
fort und macht es damit ihm sehr viel
dann wissen wir auch eine angel ann
christin viel licht aber nicht in 12
stunden kann
den ausgang
solcher und grund nach der großen liebe
und bin ich schnell auf der hand dass es
auch spaß ohne bindung ist
wenn
man lernen und die schuhe
auszuziehen ein neues kino dann tut mir
das leid langsam aber wenn ich wirklich
weiß ich werde von der nyt wird jetzt
auch für den spaß der gal
und der schnitt notizen und warte
ich werde am pc kann ich mit dem jetzt
fordert sechs und alles möglich glaubt
schon hinter mir er ist ja auch für uns
spannend und es ist ja schön schritt für
schritt alles celle will es bis jetzt 3
wochen und 2 tage gange und mit ihm die
oft wenig erzählen kann ich jetzt ein
paar sie zwei männer offen überzieht das
heißt es wirklich jugend sprach war also
auch fürs laufende mit ihm
außer dass sie zwar nicht das
erste was der kollege von uns waren aus
freundin die freundin nicht genug dass
ich ministerin gehen aber es ist auch
eine messe wieder hand und um an mich
und so sieht man aber erst sagen
wenn ich erzähle ja ich schnappe meine
würde ich und meine abschläge hat sich
einmal würde mitmachen
ich bin ein es ist natürlich hart da
jeder habe ich alles land und das
einfach ohne gefühl und ich habe mal
üppig mit einkehr im ausgang ländern hat
man auch greta man abgemacht haben sich
die kollegen vorgestellt und man beide
wissen zu sammeln und nach einem
miteinander schlafen sich wunderschön
und
das heißt das
thema
was mich aber keinen druck machen
das verstehen die sagen das sei für ihn
stimmt
und wir haben das machen
natürlich stellten sich wo es wird
perfekt
und ich mich mit dem schon zwei jahre
zusammen das hat mir alles besprochen
man muss einfach sagen ich sagen wenn
ich jetzt bin ich auswähle wartet
2 habe ich kann
werde ich jetzt nur jungfrau und dass
wir mit einem kleidungsstück
das erste mal habe ich mit 15 mann chris
katongo und
er trotzdem darauf bestanden und
das vorspiel und wenn es trotzdem dank
gemacht aber trotz wird über rückseite
damit der
zweite film fertig
ist
hat das gefühl nach fünf minuten oder so
aber nicht
wählen will einfach ein schlechtes
gewissen wenn falsche freundin hat
kaum hat und hatten halt das schlechte
gewissen hatte nicole und hat uns klüger
ja wir könnten morgen vor dem vfgh heil
auf die post und das ist ein heikles und
teilweise sagen gut hätte letztlich
seele warte bis du
musst dich nicht umbringt mit dem
zusammen sie aber
wenigstens nicht
das mache ich
glaube das ist wenn es kleine läden ist
romantisch vor
[Musik]
dass eine peg und damit
die
möglichkeit
alle
seiten völlig erben von hat sich aber
niemand
herzig von
uns gegangen habe ich immer ein tango
immer
das was mein ist billig
[Musik]
das komitee
die
doch mal
in zürcher szene club xtra steigt die
news sommer surf party mit whirlpool und
champagner
nein
ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich bin christ lampe erfreulich
16 uhr ab ich möchte mich nicht für
stiefel und sagte entweder habe ich ein
freund unseres lauf gar nicht sondern
ich glaube das leben so wie es herr und
frau das erscheinungsbild das reh sicher
sind und nicht so schnell vorwärts aber
das gefühl
das war eigentlich genauso schnell sind
wählen oder könnte wie man im alltag ist
auch offensichtlich dass das jetzt
abhaken mit mobook mögliche zweite
metalle und
frauenfeindliche diskrete und und den
tag langsam
langsam frage hab mich in genau gleicher
ziel eigentlich
[Applaus]
das sagen
[Musik]
es sind sogar zwillingsbruder xii wir
sind es nach hilfen koordinieren tore
gemacht und dann gab beschluss vom albig
als ottone mit einer
nicht so
etwas hat
die situation im sport
bestätigt dass jugendliche immer früher
noch immer will der immer umkämpft die
sexualität uns lieb ist projektion vor
den erwachsenen
das ist schon frühere generationen so
sie und ich danke euch mal vor ganz
schön wenn sich aber wachsen würde
zurück erinnere wie sie sich damals
unsicherheit filtern wo sie ihre
aufkeimende sexuelle vielen texten wo
sie sich sehr schnell verliert haben und
das heutige jugendliche den meisten
situationen gar nicht viel anders kommt
wann ist es liebe
im freundet sich das personal für rote
rosen rote
rose genau wie ich meckere nervös
und er hat erst gar nicht
ganz sprachlos gemacht
am morgen
danach gesagt dass ich mich ganz
spezieller moment das so vorstellen als
gesicht
der vorhergehende comics und es kommt
immer auf den weg durch vw zeigt was er
schreibt ich dann ist das
schon
fertig
sein bis komplex
naja in die wissenschaft ich find's
schön wenn man mal
stücks hat will dann kommen immer wieder
bezirk und wenn wir mal immer stärker
durch das irgendwie ist wann kann ich
nicht beantworten weil es erstens
verliert sie bin mit paul und chaos
schmetterlinge im buch
sechs wichtigsten fotolia
[Musik]
gerät aber wenn man miteinander
697 alles erzähle
man daher begehrt so zeigen haben wir
darunter oder die andere hübsch findet
so dass ich sehr viel kraft
die zehn jugendlichen freuen sich an
lust und liebe manchmal ist es
kompliziert schmerzhaft und meistens gar
nicht so enthemmt
war das nicht immer schon so
[Musik]